it turns out and there's a now quite a
history of this relatively recently
people have found that there are a lot
of species who can do number tasks by
number to us I mean tasks which depend
upon understanding the number of objects
in the display or what we would call
numerosity so you have to be very
careful here because you can't talk to
other species and they can't talk to you
so you can't explain to them what
aspects of the stimulus you want them to
respond to but you but you have to
design the the stimuli rather carefully
so that the critical aspect of the
stimuli is the numerosity of objects
actually before the Second World War a
brilliant German ethologist called Otto
Kerner had shown that corvids crows
jackdaws and so on had quite a good
number sense that they could match to
sample numbers up to about seven so he
showed them a sample of black blobs and
then they had to select one of a two or
three objects which had the same number
of blobs the blobs would be arranged
differently if they got it right they
got rewarded if they got it wrong they
didn't and they were pretty good at this
these corvatz since then there was a
been since the 30s there's been kind of
a hiatus in research on on animal
numerical cognition but in since the 90s
it's really started to take off again
and we now know that the whole range of
different animals couldn't can do this
both in the wild and in laboratories
particularly in the borough trees we
were interested in the counting
abilities of fish now small fish often
swim in shoals and if they are in a
shoal
there's a smaller risk of predation than
if they're by themselves and if they're
in a bigger show they've got a smaller
risk of predation than if they're in a
smaller shoulder safety in numbers the
safety in numbers exactly so you can use
this natural behavior of of these small
fish
and test it in the laboratory so you can
put them in a transparent tank with a
few fish on this side and a few more
fish on the other side and you see which
side they they swim to it's been shown
not by me but by my collaborators that
they will swim to the shoal of the side
of the of the tank with more fish in it
what we were interested to do in in a
paper we published this year was to see
whether they had a difference between
small number perception and large number
perception so in humans what happens is
that if you have to compare four versus
three four versus two four versus while
three versus two this is all equally
easy it doesn't depend on the ratio of
one number to the other so four against
one is just as easy as four against
three however once you get larger
numbers let's say eight against seven or
eight against five then there's a ratio
effect that is the bigger the difference
between those two numbers the easier it
is the question is would this be true of
Guppies which are a small fish about
that big relatively small brain and the
answer was yes that these small fish
didn't show a ratio effect when we you
ask them to compare four versus one as
compared to four versus three but for
larger numbers they did show a ratio
effect which suggests that like us they
have these two systems small number
system and a larger number system and we
thought this was really quite an
intriguing result I can imagine someone
at home thinking well surely the fish
just looks at two different groups of
fish or shoals of fish and can just
measure which ones bigger which one
takes up more volume and swims towards
that and it hasn't used any number sense
there it's just used and understanding
of how big something is how was the
experiments that you've been involved
with getting around that well it's very
difficult to control because not only
are there more fish over here there of
course swimming around
and you can have fewer fish over there
they're swimming around so it's really
quite difficult for the the the subject
fish to be able to make an estimate but
even though they do it actually rather
well how do we know that their enumerate
in the fish this side versus that side
well there are ways in which you can
manipulate the amount of fishness on
this side and the amount of fishness on
that side for example by putting
slightly larger fish on this side to
balance the number of fish on that side
that creates some problems because of
fish psychology which I not an expert in
like some fish prefer to swim in shoals
with larger fish and so you know that
creates complications however my
collaborators have done a nice training
experiment in which the fish doesn't
have to choose between two shoals
it has to select a gate into another
tank to join its friends and above the
gate will be a number of blobs and the
fish has to choose the right number of
blobs it would have had a training
session in which a certain number of
blobs would be rewarded and a different
number of blocks would not let say 3 is
rewarded 2 is not rewarded in the test
there be different blobs but there'll be
3 nests and tunas so different
arrangements of treatments and tunas and
the fish can learn this actually can
learn it quite well so there's now quite
good evidence that the fish can respond
to to number but of course they might
also in in the wild be responding to
other cues like the amount of fishiness
in in the neighborhood and of course
these are typically correlated with the
number and so you you want to try and
tease them apart experimentally but in
in real life of course they they they
tend to go together
how does understanding the mathematical
cognition or the number cognition of
gabbi's help anything why why have you
got interest in this well we want to
know what kinds of capacities the the
human brain inherits